i think the nhs could create massively
greater patient satisfaction by
deploying certain behaviors and
techniques like what
well
rory sutherland he is an author
columnist and the vice chairman of
ogilvy uk one of the largest marketing
companies in the world he's an ad man
the stories are the pdf files of human
information they're the vehicle we use
for storing information and the vehicle
we use for sharing it if you want to
improve how people feel psychology is a
better area for exploration than
rational improvement don't make the
eurostar faster make the journey more
enjoyable and that's one of the
cleverest reframings you can do
the uber map is a psychological moon
shot what bothers us about waiting for a
taxi isn't actually the duration it's
the degree of uncertainty and if you
have a map which shows you where the
taxi is you're basically relaxed you can
genuinely perform magic in perception
what is the seat covering for the tesla
it's called vegan leather now actually
to be honest we would have called those
plastic seats back in the day if it
makes things feel more valuable
is it a con
without further ado i'm stephen bartlett
and this is the diary of a ceo i hope
nobody's listening but if you are then
please keep this to yourself
[Music]
brewery
first of all thank you for being here as
as someone who
built a marketing business and has
worked in a sort of similar industry um
to you for a huge portion of my life um
you're someone that i've always looked
up to and even young members of my team
here cite you as being an inspiration on
an ongoing basis for the work they're
doing just broadly on some even of these
new platforms like tick-tock because the
principles and the psychology and the
the sort of rationality underneath much
of your work is is really really
timeless um so thank you for being here
what a great honor
and um but we'll get into some mutual
fanboying later um but no i mean i one
of the great insights i think which i
hope helps motivate everybody working in
our industry and related industries is
that when you create perceptual value
you are creating value value can be
created in the mind every bit as much as
it can be created in the factory
and i think there was a an unfortunate
story about marketing that treated it as
a kind of optional extra it was the
fairy dust on top of the real intrinsic
value that resided in a product or
service
and i completely dispute that i think we
value things according not to what they
are but what they mean and what they
mean is context dependent it can be
massively transformed by storytelling
framing recontextualization
and you can absolutely use psychological
mechanisms to make things more valuable
more enjoyable more precious
that's one important part i might make
the additional point which is
to be honest overambitious but i make it
anyway which is that actually perceived
value is a very environmentally friendly
form of value to create
because you can generally create meaning
and imbue a product with meaning
um with a lot less carbon consumption
that is necessarily involved in making
the product three times bigger or five
times faster
and you know my argument would also be
if we're looking for breakthrough 10x
moonshot improvements
it's actually much easier to find
psychological moon shots than
technological moon shots you know making
a train ten times faster you know it was
possible in 1840 1820 okay it's very
difficult to do now um to a point of
just dangerousness or you know
extraordinarily difficult uh engineering
problem making a trained journey ten
times more enjoyable
that's still doable in my view give me
an example then what's the example that
always comes to mind for you of where
someone has managed to put tremendous
moonshot style value on something
a brand potentially
just with marketing and advertising but
what i'm always very fond of is i think
the uber map is a psychological moonshot
and it's based i mean the the story
which may or may not be true is that one
of the founders of uber was inspired by
watching goldfinger and when he saw bond
effectively following goldfinger using a
tracking device there was a scrolling
map in the dashboard of the db4 which
showed him where goldfinger's car was so
he could trail it while remaining out of
sight
then um
what was extraordinary about that was
that it was based on a very clever
insight into human psychology which most
of us ourselves aren't really aware of
which is the we would say and we'd
confidently say we believe that i hate
it when a taxi takes a long time to turn
up i like it when a taxi turns up
quickly
so a rational person or an engineer
would react to that by saying what we
need is a predictive algorithm so that
taxis tend to be available in areas
where we predict heavy demand so that we
can service customers more quickly and
by the way there's nothing wrong with
that it may be a very worthwhile thing
to do although it's worth saying that it
requires quite a lot of scale
in order to achieve that
but the real insight with the map is
that deep down you know somewhere in the
amygdala what bothers us about waiting
for a taxi isn't actually the duration
it's the degree of uncertainty in other
words is he here yet maybe he's part
round the corner or what if he can't
find the house maybe he's already left
was the person on the phone lying and so
wait that period between booking a taxi
and waiting for it to arrive was one of
general high stress now what's
interesting is you could reduce that
stress i admit by getting the taxi to
turn up very quickly
or at least you'd reduce the period of
stress but the stress would still remain
on the other hand if you have a map
which shows you where the taxi is
you're basically relaxed okay
instead of going oh my god you know
where is the where is he i'm sure you
know maybe he's already left i better go
and stand out in the rain so he doesn't
miss me or get impatient you just look
at the map and you go oh look he's stuck
at those traffic lights i'll have
another pint
okay now what's interesting is that the
quantity of weighting
is the same with or without a map you
know in pure quantitative measured si
unit terms of time and duration no
difference
the quality of the waiting is totally
transformed
it's almost taking it from a system
dependent on
trust how much you trust that particular
firm have they performed in the past do
they sometimes lie to me have other taxi
drivers sometimes lied to me to a system
that is almost completely trustless or i
don't need to trust you because i can
see for myself and i suppose there's
also an element of trust which uh okay
was provided historically in london by
the knowledge
and the knowledge was an interesting
thing because i occasionally debate this
which is was the knowledge really about
knowledge in other words we don't need
black cab drivers to study to this level
of detail now we have the technology of
the sat nav yeah and pure sort of
utilitarian people go why on earth am i
paying a premium for a black cab driver
to learn all this stuff um when he could
simply buy a tom tom for 300 quid and
stick it on the dashboard and there's
some argument for that okay
the only other point is that you have a
very high degree of trust one of the
great things you could say about the
knowledge is it sunk cost it's commit
it's proof of commitment you're only
going to actually go through that
process if you're pretty serious about
being a really good cab driver
also
it provides you if you think about if
you've spent what a year and a half two
years scuttling around london on a moped
with one of those clipboards rehearsing
for your sessions of the knowledge okay
you'd be a bit of an idiot uh
effectively losing your taxi license day
one wouldn't you
okay
you know it's you know in other words it
is something it's rather like medieval
guilds they required extraordinary
stringent conditions of entry into the
guild but that was what ensured honesty
because uh the cost of being thrown out
of the guild given the effort you'd put
into actually being admitted in the
first place was therefore made it not
worthwhile to cheat you you also say
something in in your book about how
making a process more difficult can
sometimes make it more attractive to
consumers
so i mean this is known sometimes as the
ikea effect which is that um certainly
um kamprad who's the kind of owner and
founder of ikea believes that the fact
that you assemble the furniture yourself
contributes to its perceived value in
other words you've committed something
of yourself to its assembly and creation
you might also argue it destigmatizes
low prices okay so i'll give you an
example of that there's a very big
difference between cheap strawberries
and pick your own strawberries
now pick your own strawberries are cheap
but there's a narrative as to why
they're cheap which is i put into some
of the effort into the harvesting of the
things and i have to go out into a field
and pick the things myself cheap
strawberries by contrast may create some
degree of uncertainty because you look
at the market and go well if these
strawberries were really good
why wouldn't they charge full price for
them what's wrong with this
and so quite often
you know sometimes you have to make
things more expensive to make them
trustworthy oddly okay
you know you can be too good to be true
that consumers won't necessarily trust
something that's cheap unless there's a
narrative around it as to where the cost
savings are made i mean i think i think
a lot of lo if you think about low-cost
airlines okay
they spent quite a lot of effort talking
about what you didn't get you don't get
a meal okay uh you have to pay to check
in your luggage uh you don't get it
originally with easyjet you didn't even
get pre-allocated seating okay it was
you know effectively like a bus
you had to book online you couldn't book
through a travel agent
and those constraints to some extent
were there
to make it believable to the consumer
that there was a legitimate form of cost
saving going on now if you'd said if you
launched easyjet and you said we're just
as good as british airways but we're
half the price
the untrusting consumer is going to ask
how are you doing this okay does it mean
you're not servicing the engines or the
pilots are all on day release from
prison or something right you're going
to start having doubts so interestingly
sometimes negative stories around a
product
can be used to offset the negatives
which a consumer would tend to imagine
if ikea had ready assembled furniture
which wasn't sold in a warehouse it was
sold in a kind of posh heels style
emporium
we'd think there was something a bit
iffy going on
so you know and there's also the
wonderful ikea effect which is the
effort of actually going to an ikea and
navigating the maze makes it more or
less impossible for you to go home
empty-handed you know you have to buy
some tea lights at the very minimum just
to validate your trip
now the i suppose the earliest
manifestation of this although it's
sometimes called the ikea effect
was a very famous marketing case study
um for betty crocker cakes where they
had a cake mix where you just added
water put in the oven created a cake
and it didn't sell very well and a
psychologist came in
and said
there isn't enough effort involved in
this to make it feel like cooking
and so they added the slogan just add an
egg the addition of the egg although it
actually imposed a cost and a small
degree of effort
suddenly made the product much more
popular why now the idea would be that
now it was actually cooking you were
preparing something for your family you
weren't just cheating
perhaps i mean it's an interesting
debate because we don't fully know that
this this wasn't tested to an absolutely
robust level of academic uh certainty uh
you know
but nonetheless it's a very common a
very popular anecdote within marketing
that sometimes the counterintuitive i
think that's all you need to derive from
it okay all you need to derive from it
in business decision making is sometimes
the counterintuitive approach
might be better
and this i was thinking then about these
modern sort of meal delivery companies
so you have obviously on one end super
convenience you have uber ubereats etc
delivery and then you have this middle
ground of where we'll send you the
ingredients and tell you how to put it
in the pan and we'll make it so that
would be gusto or hello fresh yeah
exactly yeah but you just got to put it
in the pan and mix it and i want to only
take you 10 minutes or so which i think
is kind of probably appealing to the
same sort of psychological desire to
feel like you cooked it's a very strange
thing um because
one of the founders of gusto actually
met me shortly before lockdown
and i was i couldn't really make sense
of the product
okay at first and this by the way really
interests me because bill gates once
said of technology that the problem we
have with technology is people don't
know how to want the things we can offer
them and one of the things that
increasingly fascinates me
is products which an economist would
call them an experience good
where it's only really possible to
perceive their value by actually using
them i have to admit when i was
presented with gusto and hellofresh
i thought this is kind of dumb i've gone
you know cardo account i can order
things from sainsbury's for click and
collect i've got well my wife more
accurately has got 20 or 30 cookery
books of various kinds all i have to do
is pick a recipe from a cookery book
effectively order the necessary
ingredients
follow instructions cook at home job
done
why on earth would i want a box with
um you know pre-selected ingredients and
the right ratio arriving with a recipe
card
but anyway i met this guy and he said
i'll send you a free box now
you know
i'm not so you know ungrateful and nasty
a human being that i go i don't want
your stinking box to free food and i
think it was actually towards the
beginning of the pandemic anyway so i
wasn't entirely sure that food was going
to remain abundantly available so i said
shop you know absolutely i'm delighted
the other thing is i probably ordered a
gusto box for
um the only reason we stopped was
actually we had our kitchen replaced and
had a period with an oven but pretty
much every week
my assistant anna who's in the next room
has also had a gusto
the majority of weeks for two and a half
years ever since experiencing it
you asked me to explain this i mean this
is what's so glorious which is i can't
quite explain why once experienced this
is such a compelling benefit that's
right um
okay um
it possibly is the fact that because
these ingredients in the right ratio and
have a limited shelf life it forces you
to cook them
and therefore it forces you to cook what
ends up being a restaurant quality meal
at home with not too much effort okay
in by the way a reasonably healthy
quantity as well one of the problems
with takeaway food is
if you want variety you end up with
completely excessive quantity don't you
you end up either keeping the stuff in
the fridge or with an extraordinary
amount of food waste
because the take unlike a restaurant
where they think well if we give them
slightly too little food they might
order a pudding or something else in
take away food you don't get a second
chance to top them up so the great
paranoia i think of all takeaway
restaurants is not putting enough
quantity in
and so you do end up with a restaurant
quality meal at the price of a ready
meal um which you have cooked yourself
that's very logical they give me the
illogical
uh was there something that some
surprise and delight in i do genuinely i
don't
i've just got one product okay which is
the greatest example of a product which
genuinely kind of creates
massive contradictions in my own mind
which is the quicker i don't know if
you've got one instant boiling water
effectively oh yeah i've got one yeah
you've got one over there yeah if you
want the story of the cooker by the way
i'll tell your listeners because it's
fascinating there were two people i
think at unilever who were who their
brief was effectively to invent copper
soup
and they did it very successfully they
produced what is a powdered form of soup
and one of them said right job done
we've created the cuppa soup boil a
kettle pour the water on you've got a
nice mug of soup job done i'll go back
to the day job
and the other dutch guy
basically felt now i've only solved half
the problem here because you still have
to wait for the kettle to boil
and for whatever reason i mean he must
have been a kind of compulsive inventor
he became obsessed with solving the
second half of the kappa soup problem
which is how can we create boiling water
faster
which was technically off brief but
nonetheless for some reason absolutely
preoccupied him
and so he effectively ended up creating
what is a dutch company quicker
now okay
half of me you know perhaps the more
puritanical rational half is going
you've just paid not quite a four figure
sum but a very large three figure sum
for a very fast kettle
yeah and the other half of me is going i
wouldn't go back
you know having i don't know what your
relationship is with your cooker but i
find it difficult now going back to a
kettle having experienced instant tea
making instant soup making if you want
to poach an egg you can fill a
pan with boiling water uh
instantaneously you don't have to wait
for that to cook up suddenly of course
you discover new and complementary uses
for boiling water but that all seems
very logical to me that makes perfect
sense yeah i mean the only thing is i
think you've got a lot of products which
are much much easier for you to defend
or understand or appreciate in
retrospect than they are for you to
write a check for in advance right
and that's that's a marketing problem
the electric car by the way is i mean
one really interesting question i always
ask about any technology which i think
is a question that's asked too little
people ask what are the unit sales of
this technology and how fast are they
growing actually any new technology
grows very slowly to begin with it's a
sigmoid curve
nearly anything significantly new starts
off fairly niche yeah
and the reason is that the two driving
forces of human behavior are habit and
social copying
and therefore when you've never done it
before and none of your friends do it
doing something is much more difficult
to do and i'm old enough to remember the
time when the majority of my friends
said i don't understand why you want a
mobile phone okay i mean i can actually
remember when mo i used a mobile phone
on oxford street in 1989 two people
shouted abuse at me from passing taxis
it was like a brick
it was a social statement it wasn't my
phone it was we had company phones and
we signed them out for the day but just
the act of using one of these things in
public would expose you to a general a
program and
it's impossible for anybody now to think
back on that because i don't think
anybody knows anybody without a mobile
phone the example that i that comes to
mind for me and it's also to do with a
crooker i don't call it a cooker i just
call it the tap but yeah it instant hot
water and it's in cold water um is
music and a friend of mine told me the
story of standing with the hmv i think
it's hmv ceo looking out on the shop
floor at all these people buying cds and
he said to him we'll always have a
business because people love music now
what he got wrong is he was right that
people love music but they don't love
getting in their car driving in the rain
and then getting a plastic seed a piece
of plastic which they can then get
damaged very easily they can only carry
a few of them and driving it back to the
house people loved music and he only
really found they didn't really like cds
yes i mean i might make a point by the
way that in terms of its
if someone has a design sensibility in
terms of
its
proliferation
the cd laughably named jewel case the
plastic hinge case in which the cd came
was probably the nastiest single you
know manufactured item in everything
from environmental terms to just
usability you know the fact that it
opened with a horrible sort of cracking
snap now what's interesting is that
vinyl has made a resurgence
but i don't see any sign of a cd
resurgence any more than i see there are
a few weird people who are back into
cassettes aren't there but i think
that's fairly nichey yeah that's kind of
like lomography and photography it's one
of those sort of weird counter cultures
but
but but i can understand i just about
understand it's slightly weird when my
daughter asked for a gramophone player
for her birthday because i'm kind of
going you know i was born in 1965 i
spent my whole life trying to get rid of
the nuisance of physical music
to you know effectively something akin
to spotify and now you're weirdly
reverting to this thing you know it made
no sense to me um
possibly there's an element that if
you're really devoted to a particular
band you want to spend money and signal
your devotion in some physical form i
don't know what's going on there fully i
think is that not just a case of like
scarcity yeah i i mean well i suspect
one of the one of the curses of
capitalism is that is recursive fashion
exactly so um jeremy bulmer who's now i
suppose in his late 80s wonderful guy
who was the creative director of j
walter thompson he was a director of wpp
for many years
he made the point by the way as you get
older you realize
much more of this here we go again you
know because you have greater
chronological context in which to
appreciate it but he made the point that
when he was a child all cheddar cheese
came with a rind so most cheese you buy
in a shop was cut from a wheel and it
would have either some sort of wax or or
else rind or sometimes it's cloth on the
exterior
and someone then started selling
rindless cheddar and they charged a
premium for it you see because you know
oh brilliant i don't have to pay for the
rind and i don't have to cut it off what
a wonderful convenience
and then memories being short and
obviously some people being born before
they could remember cheddar with a rind
anyway
about 25 30 years after that people
started introducing farmhouse artisan
cheddar with the rind left on and they
charged a premium for that
so you do have this peculiar thing where
um that's all marketing there isn't
advertising because what you're saying
that's the real cheese it's it's it's
human it's partly human neophilia so
that what's different attracts our
attention okay so undoubtedly we
disproportionately pay attention to
things which are new or seemingly
different and we're novelty seeking to a
great experience what is the story
though if i buy that artisanal cheese
the story for me especially a big
artisan is this is the real cheese in my
head i immediately go that supermarket
stuff is just fake processed but the
rhine signals that this i'm paying for
real cheese well i mean we can look at
the we can look at the interesting uh
rev exactly it's a recursive trend yeah
i've got in fashion it happens all the
time that you know uh the the most
bizarre fashions including sort of
flares and um uh afghan coats have you
know sequins have made a massive
comeback
and
you um
and the truth is that when they come
around a second time the context is
different so they mean something
different you see the same with brands
like feeler like these old brands have
exploded felix isn't a good example
where it was it became when i was 10
years old you but if you bought feeler
you had no money and you weren't no no
no when i was 20 if you had feeler you
were the coolest person burberry had
that as well they went from being oh if
you're if you're wearing burberry you
are a bit of a roughy right you're a
little bit rough as a person to this
kind of i guess it was a branding
exercise where bran burberry then became
really cool again maybe because part of
the term for this is sometimes counter
signaling it was a bit like um hipsters
drinking pabst blue ribbon ribbon i
think it's called uh which is a it was
historically down market blue collar
american beer right okay okay it was
down market of kind of budweiser and the
other you know and cause and so forth
and this is a really interesting thing
in human behavior sometimes in marketing
itself but also in how humans market
themselves because i think one of the
conclusions we've got to come to and we
have to admit and which
the better understanding of will be i
think central to understanding
how we solve things like the
environmental crisis and indeed over
consumption is that the human brain
itself has quite a large marketing
function you know it has an accounting
function it cares about the efficient
use of resources it has you know all
kinds of kind of algorithms and
heuristics that are kind of in many
cases innate and built in but it also
has a marketing function it very much
cares about uh image and status
effectively what something you do means
to other people
now one thing that is
common to lots of animals is signaling
you know the most common example is the
peacock's tail elks antlers things you
do often costly things you do to
demonstrate that you can do them ferrari
okay um and you know in many ferraris in
london of course yeah you know i mean
the extraordinary thing when you think
about it is having a ferrari in central
london is about as deranged a car choice
as you can imagine okay
but the very fact that it's impractical
and ludicrous is almost what gives it
meaning okay as i said you know if the
um this is a very mischievous sentence
but if
people were attracted to people who
drove expensive vehicles okay then
they'd find lorry drivers more
attractive than ferrari owners in many
cases because the truck is actually more
expensive as a vehicle or a really
luxury motor coach
but the motor coach actually has a
practical function which diminishes its
signaling value because if you want to
show that you really have resources to
spare nothing beats waste indiscriminate
waste
shows that you really have resources to
spare you know or you pursue things that
are disproportionately scarce
the real interesting thing with humans
though and i don't think there's a case
where animals do this is they also
practice something called counter
signaling
which is showing that you don't have to
try because you're confident enough in
your other attributes
okay so an example of that would be in
academia
a a a professor who's aspiring to get a
let's say a named professorship or
tenure will go around in a suit okay
a tenured professor who has job security
for life will go around dressed like a
[ __ ] you know if you've won a nobel
prize my hunch is once you've won a
nobel prize i think famously george
stiglitz used to actually turn up at the
world bank with no shoes on okay now
interestingly you do that it's a bit
like that little joke why do dogs lick
their own balls because they can okay
and to some extent people do what they
can get away with so you know the
classic example is you know people who
play in very fashionable bands can
afford to be extraordinarily scruffy
because what effectively liam and noel
are saying is that our presence in this
band renders us so unbelievably cool and
sexy that we don't even have to make an
effort on the sartorial front i've seen
this in my own life it's funny yeah just
through the journey of my career in the
last 10 years the example i'd give is in
my early career speaking on stage i
would try and dress really smart and
wear a suit now yeah i think it's much
better that i present myself in the
tracksuit bottom in the tracksuit that i
would wear like going around the house
when i speak on stage a because it's
more akin to who i am b because i can
yeah and c i think the psychological
thing that i'm not admitting because it
might make me seem like an [ __ ] is
it's actually more of a status play to
not wear a suit and to not show off and
the same applies for louis vuitton like
early part of my first five years of my
career when i was just about getting
some money i'd buy these designer brands
like louis vuitton now
i genuinely think if i hold a louis
vuitton
bag it makes me look bad
so i i've like rid myself and when i
walk in somewhere i say to my manager
because i've just got the one left that
hasn't managed to break yet i say can
you hold that because i don't want to be
associated with
that level of signaling if that makes
sense i guess no and the argument is
that you know you're famous enough now
that you no longer need fashion brands
um uh to accord you know
in fact the very fact that you were
trying um uh given your fame to actually
uh signal your success through fashion
would probably be counterproductive it
would suggest you were insecure or
trying too hard yeah and so that thing
of we do what we can get away with to
signal what we're you know what we're
capable of so it's a very oblique form
of status signaling it might be very
valuable environmentally counter
signaling might be something you need to
harness
in other words it's cool you know
it's cool to own less yes because i
don't have things i don't have a watch i
don't have as i said to you i have an
electric bike which you've just seen i
have to be fair i do have a nice cut um
car that they drive me in sometimes but
other than that in terms of my own
possessions it's really all about
utility yeah and not buying it in excess
and i actually think that's a really
good point that that can be leveraged to
try and um help the environment
which i i think that's happening there's
a very interesting thing happening which
is in electric cars and i was speaking
to the marketing director of skoda they
produced something called the enyak
which is actually it's similar to the
volkswagen knight e4 but it's very very
good electric car and one of the things
they're noticing i migrated from a
jaguar to the ford mustang machi
um quite a few people on the mackie
forum are actually ex-luxury car owners
and quite a few people um the
the skoda marketing director was telling
me
um that quite a few people who'd gone to
the skoda eniac could actually come from
for example audi jaguar
fairly premium cars
so there is a thing that actually having
the electric car
even in a you know a less leather clad
you know
wall that infested form
that's now the status component it's not
the brand of the car it's the fact that
it's electric tesla's the same i think
tesla is a big um i don't give a [ __ ]
in a weird way i think it's a big for me
it's a
um the journey honestly would be you
you'd get a lamb if you were insecure
and this is what you're into you get one
of those really fancy brands and then
the next step is saying do you know what
i don't give a [ __ ] which is what you
see going on in san francisco with the
billionaires and the ceos and the vcs
i'm going to be a tesla person now which
is i care more about the environment and
other things and i don't really care if
you think it's still a premium brand to
be honest because let's face it any
tesla is probably less than three years
old and actually most people don't buy
cars from new ever or only once in their
life it's not fancy but it's not it's
not particularly fancy i mean there's a
wonderful piece of little alchemy in it
of course which is the invention of the
phrase vegan leather oh really if you
think that the reason i broke the book
alchemy is partly to elevate the status
and centrality of marketing in business
success
that actually what you are is
effectively a product of how you make
people feel okay ultimately
and that's psychological it's not
technological and therefore if you want
to improve how people feel psychology is
a better area for exploration than what
you might call rational improvement
don't make the eurostar faster make the
journey more enjoyable okay put wi-fi on
the trains serve better food okay it's a
cheaper way actually to compete okay
strangely engineers see it as cheating
you see if you have a an engineering or
a finance background you see
psychological value as invalid
but the vital thing about psychological
value is whereas it's very difficult to
perform magic in the world of physics or
engineering you can genuinely perform
magic in perception now what is the
what is the seat covering for the tesla
it's called vegan leather now actually
to be honest we would have called those
plastic seats back in the day in my
childhood in the 1970s and 80s we've got
it's got plastic seats okay now i'm sure
that vegan leather is better than the
plastic seats which you'd find in a
vauxhall viva in 1977 okay i'm sure it's
better in all kinds of ways
breathability you know cleanliness
whatever but nonetheless calling it
vegan leather in other words i'm doing
this for the planet rather than plastic
which is in other words what you're
doing is you're making it a choice not a
compromise
yeah and that's one of the cleverest
reframings you can do an aspirational
choice as well and indeed so yeah no and
so you know i i abs you know i look at
things like range anxiety and i get
that's psychological okay
okay range anxiety is a big obstacle to
electric car purchase oh yeah in the uk
in two in two two levels okay one it
probably well three levels one it means
that cars tend to compete on their range
which in a sense is further emphasizing
a negative to the consumer because if
electric car advertising is all about
range okay people start to see range as
more of a problem than it is secondly it
makes the batteries bigger the car's
heavier and more expensive than they
probably need to be so it's interesting
because so often i think the obstacles
to technology adoption are really
psychological hurdles much more than
technological hurdles this is why i
think marketing is so fascinating
because there are these products exactly
like gusto or holofresh which once you
experience them 50 of people become a
convert
but the real marketing challenge is well
that's fine that's great but how on
earth do you convert people in the first
place
and that's a very interesting case where
after the pandemic and this is i think
the value
i think there's a multiple value to
having occasional disruptions in life
one of which is that businesses become
much less risk-averse
when they're facing a crisis
it's a necessity as the mother of
invention
but consumers also have a narrative for
why they're doing things differently
i mean in a way you could if you looked
at the whole
path of human history the 1930s in the
united states i.e the decade immediately
after the great depression was probably
the period of greatest innovation
in terms of you know human welfare in
everything from cars aircraft etc it was
an extraordinary period of innovation
and yet it came on the heels of this
total economic disaster
and i think there is something there in
that idea that um it's almost like
annealing when you make a samurai sword
you actually bang the thing while it's
cooling that actually
some periods of disruption that some
degree of variance and instability in
economies is possibly long-term healthy
i mean i i i'm a huge devotee more so
than you i know you've got a very
intelligent approach to flexible working
which is yeah that's what i wanted to
talk about yeah but but it was
interesting it was interesting that
given the fact that the whole promise of
the internet really i mean i think this
is in a douglas copeland book called
microsurfs where one of the geeks who
features in this douglas copeland book
it was written in the 90s i think but he
makes a very interesting comment which
is the whole purpose of
what you might call silicon valley
technology is to make location
irrelevant in other words it's to make
where you are irrelevant to the
performance of a particular function
and by the way there are negatives to
that there were great positives in my
childhood to the fact that what you
could do was constrained by where you
were so when you left the office you
couldn't meaningfully work okay because
your computer was on a desk you
photocopied in the photocopier room you
met in the meeting room you you know you
you wrote things at a time at a keyboard
where you were determined what you were
doing and so a certain focus arose from
that which i think has been destroyed by
the mobile phone to some degree which
technically lets you do anything from
anywhere i find myself on holiday and
day three worrying about what i'm going
to order from ricardo when i get home
actually you shouldn't be doing this
another thing it probably does by the
way is it encourages us to over plan and
i'm a big believer like i booked a
holiday um in
july and august and i'm trying to say to
my family no no we're going to land in
chicago we're going to leave from new
york
what we do in between those dates we're
going to leave open until the very last
moment
the the other great problem the internet
allows you to do i think with your
holiday is to plan it down to a kind of
granular level of detail which is
actually inimical to having a good time
you know a good time it often requires
spontaneity and you know
my wife and i discovered new mexico
installed american stuff we knew it
existed okay we discovered new mexico
more or less by accident we're on a
driving holiday and we got stuck in el
paso and needed to get somewhere else so
we said well let's try this you know
let's los alamos i've heard about that
right okay fairly famous okay let's go
and have a deco absolutely gorgeous
state and we've been that back five
times we discovered it effectively
through serendipity so there aren't
downsides to this you can do anything
from anywhere but it is a bit weird
that
you know trillions of dollars invested
in the capacity to to obtain
effects remotely
hadn't made a dent in the commute at all
now i'm by the way i'm totally open to
people who say entirely you know
okay airbnb has gone uh effectively
remote forever
fully remote forever now bear in mind as
a company working as a company the
entire company is is going to be 100
remote working now
there are two interesting things going
on there one of which is if you're
airbnb and your slogan is be at home
anywhere okay it's it's a bit
countercultural to demand that people
why weren't you at your desk okay
there may be an element of henry ford to
it you know that henry ford partly
created slightly apocryphal but not
entirely created a two-day weekend for
his own workers
because he thought if it actually spread
then it'll be worth people buying cars
if he could increase the salary and for
factory work and give people two days of
guaranteed leisure then you had people
who could both afford and make use of a
car
and with airbnb if you think about it uh
they stand to be fairly major
beneficiaries of working from anywhere
so doing it with their own staff there
was a rumor i'm not sure it's true so
for god's sake don't sue me on this
there was a famous rumor that unilever
created uh dressed down fridays okay
and
to be honest i think it's a conspiracy
theory i don't think this happened if it
did all credit to them and the idea was
if we could create a social norm where
people went in to work in chinos
and you know sweatshirts on a friday
we get one extra day of laundry because
you dry clean a suit but you launder a a
chinos or you launder um you know polo
[ __ ] well you're not ordinary white
shirts but you launder cotton jackets
and you know casual clothes so the
argument was it was actually a laundry
maximization ploy by either png or
unilever
not sure that's true it would be very
clever if it were but henry ford
undoubtedly did write about this that
creating leisure was part of his
strategy for selling cars
now that's interesting because
most businesses nowadays don't have that
vision to say actually
we don't necessarily have to optimize
what we do for imagined static human
economic behavior
we can actually change the way people
behave we can change what things mean we
can change whether something feels cheap
or expensive we can make feeler a really
cool brand
you know
and this is why you know i wrote the
book alchemy partly saying we have a
kind of culture in business particularly
in the finance function of business
which doesn't which refuses to believe
in magic
now i'm not saying magic is easy or that
everybody can do it all the time it's
certainly not that easy
but you shouldn't discount it because
there are vegan leather the uber map
there are magical solutions out there
i had a few words to say about one of my
sponsors on this podcast what's this one
that's sure
so do i need to mix it with water or do
i just drink it it's um no no no no no
you wouldn't put it in the water don't
put it in the water yeah
okay we'll give you a separate glass if
you want it is a
nutritionally complete it's a meal and a
drink effectively
oh fantastic
this is a this is an interesting brand
actually for many of the reasons we've
been talking about so this is the
last year the fastest growing
e-commerce company internationally and
think about what what what they're doing
so hewl our nutritionally complete
convenience
um it's basically i think it's sadly
delicious by the way delicious it's not
less quick
i'll say that so it's not like you know
raving delicious but nor should it be
because we wouldn't believe it amen if
you made it too tasty we wouldn't
believe it's medicinal properties it's
exactly like the weird taste of red bull
which i was so
two lessons are magic is possible in
psychology even if it isn't in physics
and the second lesson is sometimes the
opposite of a good idea is another good
idea
in psychology you can actually uh you
know there's dyson and there's the henry
you know they're both strong vacuum
cleaner brands in entirely different
um uh directions if you like and
the point i'm making is that i think
that high school maths encourages us to
believe that there's a single optimal
answer
uh which comes from resolving a
trade-off
and economics economics always assumes
trade-offs
i want to show you this grenade bar it's
in the drawdown
so this is this shows how what you're
saying about that the opposites can be
two good ideas because this company run
by another one of my friends both these
companies run by my friends
has taken the complete opposite approach
they are a pr a protein bar right yeah
i've bought them actually that's amazing
just as good as a chocolate bar and i'm
gonna probably tell a lie here but
i believe they are the fastest growing
chocolate bar or the most bought
chocolate bar
in the uk now they are a protein bar and
they focus entirely on taste
and they've just sold to modern delays i
think for well i know for several
hundred millions so the founder is very
very wealthy now good friend of mine
right they went for taste and they won
these have gone for
much the opposite which is really really
focused on being nutritionally complete
and healthy and i've sat in there i mean
it's not repellent it's not absolutely
not quite quite the opposite i would
drink this perfectly contently but it
tastes good enough for you to trust it
if it tasted even better i would stop
trusting it and having sat in the room
with the ceo and the founder
we they brought in these bars that
tasted like this what tasted good yeah
and there was a small compromise to the
nutritionally complete um
part in these new bars and the founder
and the managing director said no
we'd rather have bars that taste worse
and protect that nutritionally complete
sort of philosophy than to
have it taste really good and an
interesting and interesting piece of
psychology is that diet coke has to
taste slightly more bitter than standard
coke for you to believe it for you to
believe it in other words it's kind of
um
in other words you have to have that
slight little bit of extra bite because
otherwise it doesn't unit it doesn't
feel like a diet drink
well you can say a red bull you're
saying about we'll write a lot about the
interesting there's a lot about red bull
because it's this mysterious thing which
is so counter-intuitive in that you know
it tastes nastier than coke it costs a
lot more than coke and it comes in a
much smaller can than coke
and
part of that is i think it's not a drink
it's a it's a medicine i mean the whole
marketing behind it it's it's a drug
it's
and actually the promise of psychoactive
powers is delivered much better by high
price and weird taste and small portions
you wouldn't really i mean okay to give
you an extreme case there there is a
case where they discover that drugs that
upwork
for
relatively minor conditions
by which i i i let let's say as mild
asthma okay
also work for certain rare cancers
and apparently when they do this they
exaggerate the side effects
because you feel that if it's to be
tackling a much tougher challenge which
is cancer
you would expect greater side effects to
believe i mean you what you wouldn't
want is an oncology treatment which was
pineapple flavors and so there's this
weird thing which is you can
you can do things which kind of make
sense which is we want this to taste as
nice as possible and you can end up
being logically wrong rather than
illogically right yeah and i think that
distinction is really useful because
um i'll give you an example actually
nearly all pharmaceutical companies
make the pills as easy to take as
possible okay as small as possible you
know and as few needed as possible and
so forth
and when we heard this both dan ariely
and i who are on i think a zoom call at
the time said
oh dear
and they said well it's logical you know
we're designing a drug we produce the
drug how can we make the drug and we
said well
when you make something very small and
very easy to take you also make it very
forgettable
and we actually said there are you sure
we shouldn't add a degree of difficulty
should you actually require people to
grind the drug up mix it with water
because there are several reasons that
the more effort you put in the
preparation of the drug will probably
boost the placebo effect
okay
but the second thing is you'll also
create a ritual which means you'll
remember whether or not you've taken it
whereas if a pill is literally you know
you have these pills where the biggest
problem with treating the condition is
not finding the medication it's that
it's patient compliance
and we said maybe if you had a bit of a
daft ritual around this where you had to
actually grind in the pestle and mortar
and add something
you'd find much higher levels of
compliance and and a boosted placebo
effect as well really interesting that
this idea that friction can create
create value but it also can ingrain
something in your routine the other
thing that i i i think about a lot
sometimes by the way some travel
websites deliberately make the search
procedure artificially slow
because you value the results more
highly if you've had a screen that says
we're now searching easyjet british
airways al italia
and then 15 seconds later after a sort
of flurry of activity on the screen it
delivers you your holiday results
you attach more significance to those
results and are more likely to go
through and book than if it just goes
bang and gives you an instantaneous
result well i think you did a thorough
job so i trust you more if i see you've
done you've searched 50 i go okay well i
don't need to do that myself yeah you've
looked at them all for me yeah that's
really interesting i now feel scammed
this interesting and this is a sort of
philosophical question which is
if it makes things feel more valuable
is it a con
so
okay i mean
if you take this whole question of how
we perceive value you could and you
wouldn't disagree with the fact that the
nature of a restaurant
and how it's designed at the service
adds to the appreciation of food well if
it's too quick to deliver me my meal i
think they well that's
that's a very interesting point yeah
absolutely right
um so the way in which the food is
presented affects your appreciation of
the food now my argument is your your
job as a business person is to create as
much perceived value as possible
and if you okay now i was talking to jay
rainer the other day and just be clear
on this you cannot create a great
restaurant with rubbish food okay
okay that's not gonna happen
but once you reach what you might call
table stakes in terms of food quality
the things that make a restaurant great
are often
what you might call tangential to the
food or the meal itself
or you know it's it's atmosphere decor
you know
theater
who the other diners are it can be all
manner of different things and so just
as i think you're wrong running a
restaurant where you say the food is the
only thing that matters because you
could serve michelangelo food in a
restaurant that smelled of wee and
nobody would enjoy their meal even
though the food was objectively superb
um i think the worst thing you can do in
in both environmental terms and in
business terms is to create
under-appreciated value
is to go to the effort of manufacturing
something without actually working out
how to allow people to realize how great
it is scarcity and packaging um one of
the things that i'm quite i saw one of
my favorite brands the other day
do a trip around their warehouse showing
the warehouse and on one hand i loved
seeing the warehouse i love seeing the
craftsmanship that goes into it and then
they panned across to this big rail and
i saw the item that i buy and i saw like
like thousands of them
yes and i remember thinking oh [ __ ] and
and it made me reflect on what apple do
by just laying out like one of the
products on the shop floor and how much
how much more that makes me think
there's tremendous value because i just
see one ipad and one phone and one watch
there is a kind of genius to that yeah
they will the ancillary products they
will show in some sort of bulk if you're
buying mouse mats or something they
don't mind having 10 of those but the
mainstream products there is one of them
and the rest of them are kept out of
sight yeah which is very interesting
brands don't do that enough i don't
think
there is also an interesting question
about the tour of the warehouse which is
you know how much do you want to let
people in on the reality i mean yeah
because it can be like it can kill the
magic to a certain point depending on
what's going on in that warehouse it all
depends i i went out and when we were
working with lapela the famous italian
yeah you know lingerie brand and i flew
out to the there were a client of those
i flew out to italy to their warehouses
and i i read the story of golden
scissors the original founder who would
make all of the lingerie with her hands
and golden scissors and i saw these
women who all have a another woman
standing over their shoulders ensuring
perfection in the garments and my
biggest thing to the ceo of lapel at the
time was like oh my god you've never
told the story of golden figures you've
never filmed this process you're now
just competing on the high street
against um these sort of uh cheaper
lingerie brands who are selling at 30
pounds you're selling 150 and no one
knows why no because you just haven't
told you've not sort of it's what you
said about a large lounge area is a
fairly and substantial product so it's
not enough
this is the no so no one sees the
craftsmanship i had no awareness of that
either there you go and isn't that and
i'll tell you what happened to la perla
they went bust
and it and and when i got when i've seen
in italy just the unbelievable the fact
that all of the people hand-sewn they
never told that story
on a slightly more prosaic basis i
always
every time i meet kfc
i always tell them to tell people that
colonel sanders effectively founded kfc
when he was 65 years old you know he had
a convoluted career but he had spent
about eight years perfecting this recipe
for chicken and it's an extraordinary
story you know the fact that a
multinational corporation was created by
someone in there basically at retirement
age
and my argument is i can't explain
entirely why but it just makes me think
of the thing differently knowing the
knowing the foundational story behind it
can i tell you a really secret a really
easy way i've found to do exactly that
to instill any product with a apparent
sense of huge value in historical like
story is just by naming it after a
person
so if i named if i knew if i have salad
if i have italian uh spaghetti sauce
which i've just made in a factory and i
called it i don't know la la bellies
yeah you immediately think of a family
history that must have been attached to
that product and and years and years of
iteration from this family and it was so
good that people now borrowed on mass
and tesco and i think that's that for me
is such an interesting example where
just by calling it after someone who
sounds italian yup implants this whole
va you know this this story of heritage
what do you think about personalization
and when i say personalization i really
mean the surface level personalization
of
tickling someone's ego by yeah i always
talk about starbucks i'm just writing
your name on the side of the cup or this
share a coke campaign where they put
your name on it that was
instigated that brilliant idea but um um
it's very interesting personalization
because it's one of those things you
have to be very judicious about you know
it can be spooky
okay
and you know there are companies that
get it worryingly wrong
uh by essentially
uh playing back to people things that
they shouldn't know or didn't need
that
and so it's often one of those things
which i think is interesting because
it's best done obliquely spooky example
so if you know something about someone
in a personalized letter you say
you know uh you may be the kind of
person who recently did this rather than
saying you did this
and it can it can be spooky and it's one
of those very interesting things where
knowing how to play it
uh is um uh really really critical i'm
gonna give an example where i think
someone played it wrong because i was
thinking about gone yeah so one of the
this is maybe slightly different but um
i went i registered for a gym on the
other side of the world i won't say the
country because they might listen on the
other side of the world right and
30 or 40 minutes after registering for
the gym i got an email from the ceo
saying hi steve i've just seen you
registered for our gym
um if there's anything i can do while
you're in town please let me know blah
blah blah now on one hand people might
think that's that's great and that's
lovely of them to do
but i don't know how that individual got
my details so i gave it to an ipad on
the front desk to a nice indonesian lady
right and then the ceo who's a british
person is clearly what else did they see
of my details did they see my my
password do they see my bank details so
it just kind of it hurt me it was cool i
was a bit shook by it i was like how in
35 minutes since i put that details into
the ipad has the ceo in the uk emailed
me email not just has emailed my manager
and then i'll give you a good example
which is i flew to india
i got to a hotel in india and as i went
into the room they had a chocolate taj
mahal and they had my company logo
social chain and a small rice paper
sticker on the the thing and i thought
that that made me feel special yeah
one of them made me feel like they'd
invaded my privacy a little bit and the
other one made me feel really special
and i took my phone out and i do loads
of instagrams about this hotel and this
taj mahal rice paper sticker that cost
two dollars
so you're right there is a fine line
there and you can i mean it's very
interesting because there's all you've
also got to be very very alert to
cultural differences so that germans
have a paranoia about data protection
and privacy uh which is an order of
magnitude greater than that you find in
say the u.s
where i think most people in the u.s
kind of have the mentality that the
horse has already bolted it's too late
everybody already knows all this stuff
so leaving aside things like medical
data and stuff that is you know
naturally expected to remain secret
um because i thought with the machine
it's funny because when you put your
details into computers and like login
forms and registration yes you assume
they're going into some vaults it never
occurred to me that because now because
you'd self-inputted it yeah um you'd
assumed that effectively it was
anonymous yes and it was going into some
vault in a computer yeah that was
encrypted and secure so to get an email
35 i go well
these people saying all my data
everyone's got my phone number he's got
my password
and that was just felt like a bit of a
what's interesting is you you found it
unpleasant
another person otherwise demographically
identical to you would be cool with it
yeah they thought it was yeah great
customer service generally it's probably
it's probably a caution that people who
work in marketing
are
less
um
likely to be sensitized to positive
possible negative interpretations of
what they're doing
because people who work in marketing are
high on openness i'll give you a lovely
example of this which i better not name
the client but it was simply there was a
special offer by a credit card company
and uh
the envelope sent out
just said final reminder in red because
the offer was about to expire
okay
and we thought it was you know
reasonably cute you're going to open a
letter with final reminder on it and
it'll tell you that you've only got 10
days left to enjoy this particular
discount
and a significant minority of people
went bananas with this
and the reason was you know they said
that to a londoner this is
incomprehensible okay if you live in
london or you live in a large city
now my postman thinks i don't pay my
bills
because they've received a letter with
final reminder on the outside of the
envelope now most people in london don't
really know their postman and they
certainly wouldn't worry about their
postman going around and gossiping about
them because in a place like london
there's a left
anonymity if you live in a small country
village totally different matter because
the postman drinks at the same pub as
your friends oh yeah of course that's
one of those cases where
nobody working on the thing had had any
consideration because londoners wouldn't
be bothered by that
someone who shares a doormat with five
other people might be bothered by that
let me give you let me get i want to get
some rules um some advice from you then
so i'm i'm launching a
a brand soon
and it's an apparel brand and we've been
working very hard on it over the last
year or so maybe a bit too hard on it
when when it comes to delivering that
apparel brand to the world and making it
um it's actually an extension of this
podcast so it's called doac dyro ceo um
what advice would you give me as it
relates to delivering that product to
the world to make sure that it is
inherently valuable and that
people you know uh one one piece of
advice in any form of uh e-tail two two
forms of advice actually
uh the two mr and by the way i think
marketers spend too much time focusing
on the addition of positives
when a lot of time needs to be spent on
the removal of negatives uh one thing is
answer the phone
okay and do not hide your phone number
[Music]
i find that so what seems to happen in
most e-commerce is you have what you
might call the sales area which is
everything that happens
up to
and including a point of purchase
and everything there is glorious and
attractive and you know and slick
okay assuming by the way you don't have
a weird question to ask
um but i would argue one
um what then happens is if something
goes wrong with your experience either
the delivery of the experience or you
need to cancel something
as soon as you deviate from that very
narrowly preconceived sort of purchase
funnel
you enter a world of pain okay and the
two things which are i think grossly
under under invested in uh in terms of
e-commerce are one
giving what tends to happen is once once
the marketing job is done because the
person has clicked buy
the responsibility for that customer is
now handed over to people whose metrics
are anything but customer satisfaction
their cost reduction how can we make
sure that nobody phones us up how can we
make sure that every phone call is as
brief as is feasibly possible and how
can we minimize the cost of delivery and
distribution
now one of the things i think is a
grotesque mistake that most e-commerce
providers make not all of them but many
is not offering you a choice of delivery
couriers
for example
okay
now i know why they do that they want to
put everything through one delivery
courier so they can maximize their
rebates through volume economies of
scale
actually i think you know i think many
me two problems happen there one if you
don't get to choose how your items
delivered if anything goes wrong you
blame the company you don't blame the
delivery company or yourself if i'd
chosen to have it delivered by royal
mail and it went missing i'd blame royal
mail if they insist that i have it
delivered by you know without singling
out ups dpd whatever and it goes wrong i
blame them
um secondly you know people have various
preferences
you know your liking for every used to
be called um uh
hermes okay varies enormously depending
on which postcode district you're in
because if you have a very good local
driver it's incredibly good and if your
local driver is off sick it's a disaster
in some cases okay
um and by not resp not respecting the
the fact that the person is paying for
the delivery should choose who delivers
it
strikes me as a fundamental failing the
business of hiding the phone number
so that anybody who has a problem is
effectively treated like a second class
citizen so you have this very
characteristic thing which i think is a
problem with e-commerce which is when it
goes well it's miraculously good okay
but the second anything out of the
ordinary happens you enter a world of
pain
you know um and i think that is that's a
fundamental failing this is a customer
service point the importance of customer
service right a few people i mean
selfridges self just do it pretty well
okay um other things i do is i would
offer a kind of amazon prime equivalent
where if you pay a few pounds for
delivery you get free delivery for a
year that seems to be a you know fairly
obvious brilliant idea because why
should loyal customers pay you know
inordinately more for you know delivery
than one-off customers do
um i think you know i think you can make
an effort around how the thing is
delivered and packaged and presented
which some people do well and some
people don't bother to do at all what do
you think the secret is there to doing a
good job with packaging um possibly
there's a little bit of costly signaling
involved i mean if you order something
from selfridges um
the
inside of the box is actually yellow
with the selfridges logo on a kind of
shiny backdrop and there's a little bit
of tissue paper
okay
so you're never left um that will have a
halo effect on your perceived value of
the product by the way
you know i know we don't like it but
actually packaging is to some extent
packaging is where a product first
becomes a brand
it's where it first takes on a
personality and identity uh you know
you know a kind of an implied target
audience
and so in in this thing now the
interesting thing is how are you going
to
uh what's your shtick do you have for
example scarcity is the clothing
available yeah so limited runs we
actually we actually sold some before
when i did a tour of the uk and you had
to come to the tour to buy it and every
single night on the tour we did nine
nine nights three nights at the london
palladium took it up another country and
sold it every single night every single
item to the point that we sold the ones
on our backs yeah and we'll gave them
away but um every single item sold out
and every single size on the tour so
this is like the second drop of it
everyone's well aware that the first the
first run of it all sold out um we have
a very limited line uh
we have a limited amount of items again
this time
and i think the key thing with this um
release is
we've just agonized over the story of
the piece so it's like it really looks
more like art than it does clothing and
we've worked with artists and there's
this big movie that i'm releasing with
every single item to explain the meaning
of the piece and then we've put a lot of
effort into the packaging the unboxing
experience so it is limited it will
honestly probably sell out in the first
day
and um
i don't even think we're gonna make
money from it but that's not really why
i do it it's more because i just love
the i love the process but um
probably will you probably will make
money i mean merch is um
i'm just really not bothered by making
money from it it's not the thing in my
life same with a tour like i spent every
penny i could on the bloody tour because
it wasn't really why i was doing it
there's probably more of a bra a wider
brand play yes to doing it which is like
it's it's bringing our audience closer
to us so it's maybe a lost leader in
terms of the financials but in the
broader engagement no i mean this is
this is actually the great curse of a
lot of modern business given the title
of your um podcast
which is that
people generally over obsess about
things which are immediately
quantifiable and under invest in things
which are valuable but hard to actually
put a figure on yeah and so things like
engagement or loyalty of course i mean
it's worth noting that customer loyalty
is much much slower to measure than for
example conversion yeah and so the
extent that money's invested in
performance marketing or the bottom of
the funnel relative to let's say wider
brand fame yeah it's a widespread
problem in the whole business world
which is that the money isn't
necessarily being spent in in the in the
channels it is because it's more
effective there but simply because it's
more of it's easier to prove
that it has an effect the truth of the
matter is the world will always be too
uncertain for us to know who our
customers are in advance
and therefore since you know 97 of the
potential customer base aren't in market
at any given time and therefore won't be
uncovered by search or you know
remarketing or whatever
spending money on the 97 of people in
advance ahead of times
is still a very effective thing to do
the reason people do too little of it is
that it's hard to quantify on that
particular point then having worked in
the advertising industry this is a
conversation we have all the time with
clients which is that you'll meet a
certain type of client who is very uh
who's they're religious about the bottom
of the funnel they're really if it if i
can't track it and i don't know exactly
i won't do it i won't do it then you'll
sometimes meet the opposite
which is yeah someone who just loves to
spend on brand
and i don't know they're both wrong yeah
i don't think they should yeah i mean i
mean mark ritz very good marketing
professor always talks about the
importance of both ism and he says it's
vitally important that when i actually
speak about the importance of brand
marketing
that you do not interpret this as
denigrating digital marketing in fact i
go a bit further and say the bottom of
the funnel in many respects is the thing
you have to optimize first
because there's no point in actually uh
if there's a bottleneck at the bottom of
the funnel if there's some constraint or
a problem or a failing uh you know if
you have very poor conversion okay
there's no point in spending money on
advertising because you'll just
introduce more people to a disappointing
experience you're wasting money so
you've got to get the back end and i
would argue the first thing in theory
you should optimize if you're being an
absolute purist is repeat purchase
because having gone through the expense
to acquire these customers and actually
that's the that's the metric that always
fascinates me because
we were talking earlier about electric
cars and i said the question about
electric cars isn't how many people are
buying them okay it's not what
percentage of the new car market in the
uk in july were plug-in vehicles
now only question worth asking really in
the long term is
does anybody who buys an electric car go
back to buying a gasoline car
because if the answer that is hardly
anybody then okay you don't know the
exact shape of the s-curve but you know
the growth is going to be pretty
spectacular and so the thing to
understand i think in a market is to
what extent does your uh product
actually convert someone to something
hmm and then the lifetime and so you'd
start with repeat purchase then you go
to conversion and then you'd work your
way up but what tends to happen is that
when people are obsessed are obsessed
with quantification of everything okay
it's worth noting by the way that all
big data comes from the same place the
past
all right so there's a limit to how much
big data particularly if you've had some
major event like a pandemic in between
how much big data can actually tell you
about the future in any case
as david ogilvy famously said you're not
advertising to a standing army or
advertising to a moving parade people
are coming in and out of market all the
time
and so
you're absolutely right you get some
people who are just fame junkies and by
the way i suppose there are brand
categories where that's appropriate if
it's sold through retailers you know in
other words if it's mostly sold in the
physical space you might you know you
might argue to an extent you know for
let's say a burger king or a mcdonald's
that's not a totally crazy position
although it is now because suddenly
they've got to think about delivery and
and whether people order through the app
or order through an intermediary because
it has a major bearing on their business
but
but at the same time yeah i mean the
tragedy is this idea of this false
dichotomy between brand advertising and
what you might call performance or
digital marketing as if you have to be
in one camp or the other
where is the balance though and how does
one go about is it just intuitive is it
just there are figures on this so if you
look at the work of um
liz burnett for example in peter field
the ratio shifts a little bit but
generally they'll stipulate a figure
around about the 60 40 mark in favor of
what you might call brand mass media
uh expenditure because they have a a
mutually beneficial relationship
my obviously 20 years of my life was
spent in direct marketing and actually
you know
because direct marketing was
unfashionable we spent a lot of time
denigrating advertising spend because
they got much bigger budgets than us not
necessarily rightly but they were also
you know much more indulged than we were
because they didn't have to prove
effectiveness down to the same sort of
level of statistical significance
but we came to realize pretty quickly
that actually
um first of all there's nothing harder
than direct marketing a product that
nobody's ever heard of yeah and that
every time just to give an example every
time american express went on television
or advertised big in mass media the
response rates to direct mail would
not quite double maybe but they
increased pretty significantly you had
to work less hard and you had to work
it's that wonderful phrase which comes
from a book by uh let me get his job
right uh his his name right um
uh i i think it's matt johnson who's
just written a book called um uh brands
that mean business and his wonderful
line is having a great brand means you
get to play the game of capitalism in
easy mode yeah
and that's
and what what is true is fame to some
extent
brings a load of benefits which aren't
necessarily sales related so for example
you can [ __ ] up and your customers will
be more forgiving
okay uh take the example of apple i mean
on a couple of occasions apple has
produced products which had fairly major
flaws
which might have proved pretty fatal
to lesser brands you know the famous
phone where if you held it in the wrong
way it didn't make phone calls for
example
and um given the reality distortion
field around the apple brand people have
passed over those incredibly rapidly and
so
they're all you know people are less
price sensitive
that's not easy to measure by the way as
well it's very easy to measure the
extent to which something has an effect
on sales
but the effect to which something has an
effect on price elasticity and the
extent to which you can command a
premium because it's a great brand
because it's a great brand it's harder
to measure because you don't have the
counter factual you know when you sell
something the counter factual is that
you assume that you wouldn't have sold
it otherwise
but if you sell something for a high
price
you can't in fact determine that without
your advertising you wouldn't have sold
it
for you know for that for that premium
price so it's it's to some extent this
quest for perfect measurement
to to reduce marketing to a kind of
newtonian physics is a bit of a false
god fame you talked about fame there
fame can also be applied in the topic of
personal branding as well obviously
social media has allowed us all now to
build our personal brands you've got the
gary vaynerchuk's of the world who have
built you know
you know their companies are famous
because they've they've branded a person
at ogilvy and within your sort of your
marketing what kind of shift have you
seen in the desire for people to become
brands themselves and how valuable do
you think that is
i think advertising always had those
personal brands and if anything it's
slightly diminished actually really um
uh
campaign magazine always did a very good
job of you know making sure there were
30 or 40 sort of famous names within the
within the business
that just happens in a different medium
now right it happens on linkedin
yes i agree i mean you know so i mean
one of the greatest things for example
there's a wonderful wonderful guy who
now must be i don't want to name his age
but he you know he's you know past
retirement age called dave trott you
probably know dave okay
he'd be a brilliant interviewee by the
way on the show absolutely fantastic but
what has been absolutely fantastic is
that um
you know he's a glorious advertising
mind i mean just an absolute ornament to
the industry and he through twitter and
through
blogging
has had a completely new lease of life
and influence to a completely new
generation of people
um and has been you know hugely valuable
as a teacher and what's interesting
about that actually is that of course
uh he does that unpaid
and one of the things that is
complicated about this new world okay
you know the most valuable thing i often
do in the course of a working week
is either to give something away
or to put somebody in touch with
something else
neither of which you know that kind of
barter
um neither of those things is in any way
monetizable is it well reciprocity would
say otherwise yeah i know i suppose
you've just got to rely on a high degree
of reciprocity in some respect i mean
always it always bothers me about this
which is that we're in a business
advertising which is paid by the hour
which is a terrible way to pay for ideas
because the value of something has no
relation to the time
uh devoted to its inception
and um
it is genuine i mean you know i always
joke about this the most valuable thing
i probably did was almost accidentally
my working life which was to go to the
government's behavioral insights team
and as a sort of fanatical vaper i'd
been a long time smoker and had been
able to quit for the first time
successfully by switching to vaping it
took me a little while but once i'd made
the switch i've never gone back
um
[Music]
and i went to the government's
behavioral insights team and i said look
um these things are coming over from
both japan and the united states they're
electronic cigarettes i think there are
two things you need to be alert to in
psychology one of which is that um
because they actually replicate the
habit of smoking not just the nicotine
they are a major kind of what you might
call a gateway drug out yeah they're a
major source of harm reduction at the
very least uh it may help people to quit
uh at the very least it'll help people
to shift to something a much less
harmful delivery device versus patches
versus patches and guns and things like
that which didn't replicate the behavior
and then the second thing i said is the
second thing you've got to be alert to
is that because of peculiar human
psychology half the people in the what
you might call the health and
anti-smoking lobby will be fanatical
about banning electronic cigarettes
and all credit for the behavioral
insights team um under a guy called
david halpam i think they went to the
cameron government and said favor here
can we have a light touch on vaping
regulation please
and various parts of the eu have gone
for much stricter regulation there were
some countries which were more or less
banning it the u.s has banned jewel for
some reason bizarre on that on that
point of personal branding though do you
think building a personal brand is
important
yeah
it's very interesting i mean you have a
personal brand whether you like it or
not but that's one really important
point about branding which is
that everybody you know and that's by
the way why i think marketing is so
important because it's not the brand is
not the heated steering wheel of the
marketing world you know the optional
extra that you can do without but it's
quite nice to have
people are going to perceive you
in some way regardless of anything you
do okay they're going to form an
impression of you they're going to form
an impression of what you're worth what
kind of business you are um you know and
they will use all manner of kind of
inferences and heuristics to arrive at
this conclusion
and in many ways i suppose this is why i
argue that marketing isn't an optional
extra it's an essential because the
worst thing you can do
is build a great product and fail to
present it in a way that is convincing
appealing attractive or which confers
status on its users and the same applies
for your personal brand and the same
yeah the same price you're going to have
a personal brand whether you like it or
not so you might as well try and have a
good one i think it probably is true to
say that the personal brand requires
sacrifice you know that that old saying
that strategy is the art of sacrifice
but wait not totally true i think there
are win-wins you know what is the
sacrifice of a person
but well
i
i suspect
you don't need to suspect you've got a
personal brand yeah you you have to have
weaknesses as well as strengths now
interestingly for example one of the
things that will be part of my personal
brand is i i'm not a ceo i'm no
aspiration to be a ceo and i know enough
about myself no i would not be good at
that job okay there are certain forms of
uh of ambition and aspiration which
you know constant with with a personal
brand that i have uh are basically their
avenues that are closed to me i'm not
very good at administration i'm very bad
at making difficult decisions
self-awareness is a personal brand
strength yeah but i'm now where i'd be
useful i'd be useful at making oblique
or unusual suggestions
i'd be useful at getting people to
consider the same thing in five
different ways or uh promoting a
counterintuitive thought
i might be useful at suggesting somebody
you know
i've got fairly good personal rolodex
you know before you run off and do this
on your own why don't you talk to this
guy at this university who's been
studying this for the last 15 years
when you think about why you are
successful in your career and why you
know you're very very well known in the
industry and people speak very highly of
you why in hindsight do you think as you
look back and connect those dots you
were successful um i think
um
and by the way this is also an argument
for you know ethnic cognitive all kinds
of diversity
i really really love the advertising and
marketing industry i think it's a source
of endless fascination i think it's much
much more economically important
uh than is recognized
in the contribution it makes to
innovation to progress uh to human
flourishing actually
uh so i tend to take a fairly positive
take the only the only thing i'd say is
i've always had
half one foot out of the industry i
haven't entirely bought in
you know i never i half bought into the
awards culture let's say
but retained a degree of skepticism you
know i half buy into
purpose but but you know in other words
i haven't become
ideological about anything to some
extent i'm ideological about not being
ideological
um
you know
human psychology is immensely
complicated okay even at the level of
the individual at the level of
individuals interacting with other
individuals it is immensely complicated
i don't think it's something you can
generally pronounce confidently about
all you can do is start by asking better
questions and perform better experiments
i think and i think that's to some
extent why entrepreneurs are so
essential uh in innovation
a bit of it a bit of it is the one
disadvantage big companies have in
innovating is that it's very difficult
to get the timing right
and if you think about it while one big
company has one shot at an idea
15 entrepreneurs will launch it 15
different times and one of them will get
the timing right just by the law of
averages okay so the timing is one issue
but the other issue is that
maybe the really innovative products
require some component of
nonsense i don't mean nonsense but i
mean nonsense you know there's a degree
of
uh either sort of counter-intuitive or
seemingly illogical
quality to them i want to know about you
though okay why you were successful so
you said that
sort of unconvention maintaining
unconventional thinking and it even
actually struck me because when you said
you went to this bug convention
giving yourself another point of
reference to inspire creativity or out
of the box out of the industry thinking
is quite clearly a huge advantage yeah
curiosity is probably the kind of table
stakes in in this business if you're
generally curious what about what else
about you though um
i can i has it again i'm quite i'm gonna
okay i'm quite good at the spiel yeah
i'm quite good at my feet which i don't
know where that came from uh you know
growing up in wales is a bit of a bonus
spiel what do you mean well you you grew
up in plymouth okay now
without without disparaging people in
the southeast of england okay in the
west of england and in the celtic fringe
people talk
not just to convey information but to
prove they're good at talking there's a
kind of musical quality to celtic irish
welsh
conversation which is it's a form of
kind of regardless of the actual
information it contains people enjoy
seeing it done really well why do they
why do you think people enjoy hearing
you talk because i would agree i think
that you're a very very good talker oh
one thing um by the way which naseem
talib is very interesting on this nasim
talib always says you should mumble or
you should speak very fast
and his argument is that if you make it
slightly difficult for people to
comprehend what you're saying either by
speaking very fast or by speaking
slightly indistinctly they pay more
attention to what you're saying
i think i think there's an interesting
thing just from hearing you speak today
where
um
you're actually you're very engaging
speaker because when you introduce a
point you introduce it with a compelling
slightly ambiguous story so even you'll
net your you'll start it with that and
then the next sentence leads me up to
you're almost making me a promise of
what you're going to reveal to me in
that story
and then you deliver upon that promise
by telling me a a story and certain i
have i see her a lot with people when
they're speaking and also there's other
things like your tonal fluctuations
so if you and also your use of pausing
but your tonal fluctuations actually do
keep that maybe a welsh thing by the way
maybe so i don't have a welsh accent but
some people have said i have kind of got
welsh intonation i've sat here with
authors before and they they're so smart
but honestly i just can't i can't stay
with them because it's always like this
the whole time of the conversation is
like this so you just really it's fine
it's really you know what i mean yeah
and it's just that it's so but you yeah
see you can't you can't accuse the welsh
of not uh adding a little bit of
musicality to uh it's just interesting
when you look back in hindsight because
i genuinely believe having spoken to you
today your delivery of ideas and stories
and it's funny that i even use the use
of the word stories is such a huge part
of why you've been able to rise above
the crop and i actually think about it
with myself it's it's it's all good
having talent and genius and smarts
which you have and a lot of people have
but then the ability to equate it and to
articulate it in a way that's
captivating i think stories are the pdf
files of human information okay so
they're they're the vehicle we use for
storing information and the vehicle we
use for sharing it it's a universal
format like the pdf file you know it
doesn't matter what hardware the
recipient's got they can read the file
okay just a bit again okay so you said
you introduced a really compelling idea
that i'd never heard before i think they
are the pdf file of human information i
think what and then you have me and by a
lot of people don't do that a lot of
people don't introduce the first concept
in the sentence as being something
slightly ambiguous and unusual which
inspires curiosity via engagement so
it's it's an interesting it's probably a
habit that you have but i think it's a
very useful one for people to try and
learn so i was a classicist at
university whether i learned it a bit
uh i've been doing
i'm a big fan of classics in schools by
the way because i think first of all i
don't think you can actually decide as
an english speaker which language you
should learn in advance so learning a
language which allows you to learn other
languages more quickly may not maybe the
best approach for modern languages
ironically is to teach dead languages
and german might be an alternative
because that at least teaches you how
language sort of works
um
didn't you say something actually in
this book about this about how making
something ambiguous is actually
sometimes more effective because
yes
the idea that trump was quite a valuable
deterrent i'm not sure that they would
have invaded the ukraine if trump had
still been president because uh this is
this comes down to the realm of game
theory which is that being irrational
in some senses is is actually an
intelligent strategy because no one's
quite sure what you're going to do in
response
once you're rational you're predictable
and once you're predictable you can be
hacked
and so having some element of this is
where probably the need for human temper
and anger arises you see
if you had someone who would never lose
their temper and lash out
even at some risk to their own safety
okay
you could dick around with them almost
endlessly couldn't you if you had
someone who was 100 docile and would
just roll with all the punches and would
never lose it and would never retaliate
simply because it wasn't rational to
retaliate against say unsuitable odds i
mean there probably were people like
that but they didn't have many
descendants i think from a darwinian
point of view no you're right and
actually entirely rational people
wouldn't have spawned many descendants
because their behavior would have been
too predictable to be very easy to trap
them i just think there's a broader
point here which in which is it's i mean
it's central to advertising as well
which is people overlook the importance
of communication
huge in in
in overall outcomes and even when i sit
here with people that can speak well and
tell stories well and convey ideas well
i don't even think half the time they
realize that that's such a huge part of
their brilliance
over the course of a lifetime imagine
imagine the opportunities you'll create
the ability to sell yourself the ability
to push your ideas forward whether
they're right or wrong the ability to
inspire others and i i honestly think
well actually one of the things that's
most painful to me about watching the
dragon's den
is now i i occasionally watch shark tank
or one of the american equivalent okay
now americans have this tradition of
show-and-tell don't they way even when
you're at primary school you have to go
up and give a talk about something
and generally
i find most americans are pretty good at
you know at giving an account of
something 100
and one of the painful things about the
brits on dragon's den is sometimes
i can see the people have actually what
is a pretty good idea
but they're telling the story from like
the wrong end of the telescope
completely yeah i'm going this is this
is actually painful to me because you
have this fantastic idea
now you know okay
this is okay
slightly unethical but in a few cases i
just go look if you just invent a story
about how you came up with this okay now
apparently the whole ebay story about
pez's was never really true you know
that his girlfriend wanted to trade
pezzies
but they felt they needed a foundation
myth for how ebay got started you know
and you know i've i bet i wonder if it's
actually true that the uber came up with
the map when watching it all the time
you see these wonderful stories come up
just come up with a you know you know a
great story but also the way in which
they
um that their ability to generate
perceived value through narrative
um
is their greatest weakness
i'm watching this and i'm going this is
just painful you know i mean actually
schools should be teaching this yeah
that's what i'm saying
i mean
it leads you to worry you know are there
people out there
and by the way i'm sure this is you know
this is true
there are there must have been people
out there who had extraordinary
inventive skills
whose complete lack of marketing skills
effectively meant they died in obscurity
just even their complete lack of simple
communication skills yeah like not even
marketing is maybe step two but just
being able to tell someone else like an
investor or a potential co-founder about
their ideas in an inspiring way that
will galvanize them and get them in to
join the mission
yeah i i honestly i think the most
important skill in the world that you
could
you know give gift to a child or anyone
is just the ability to communicate
effectively tell stories and which is
ultimately what we call sales yeah and
you do it when you're meeting a girl in
a nightclub or whether you're inspiring
employees or investors or you're
building a personal brand or you're
talking to customers
the ability to understand how to keep
people um
i've got an idea i want to propose to
the government that i mean i think that
if we take marketing thinking and
alchemical thinking we can also deploy
it within politics and government and
and um uh public sector decision making
you know i think the nhs could actually
create massively greater patient
satisfaction by
deploying certain you know behaviors and
techniques just for their meaning not
for their objective medical value okay
but um like what
well
i
i'll give one example i think you could
actually reframe waiting time for an
operation in some cases as preparation
for the operation
so if that time can be put to good use
actually losing weight in my case if
ever i had to have invasive surgery okay
if they said okay the operation's in six
weeks that means you've got six weeks to
lose so many stone and this is how we're
going to do it and so the time is
actually spent improving the odds of the
operation rather than just waiting
secondly you could probably borrow a tip
from uber and you could continually
remind them of the date remind them of
milestones so they didn't feel that part
of the reason they're terrified of it
being six weeks away is because they
think it's going to shift by another six
weeks
you know it's a bit like there's a very
big difference between waiting for a
parcel to arrive which you can track
and waiting for a parcel to arrive that
you can't track
yeah so you know making making things
sort of trackable in some sense to
reassure people i think there are a lot
of psychological uh things you know just
as actually deschume ingeniously if you
have to queue for deschum they come out
and make you shy okay and they serve
chai to the waiting cue now that's very
clever because that act of generosity
inspires reciprocation
so you're much less likely to quit the
queue
i think another one i'd do is i'd reduce
student loans significantly if people
had worked for one or two years before
they went to university i think that i
think that could be a major major game
changer because at the moment why why
okay right what what happened okay this
is one of those invisible effects which
nobody notices
when i went to university in 1984 okay
okay you know i i had a private
education not a you know very good one
actually and i i went to cambridge in
1984 okay then if you had a degree from
let's say a russell group university
it was um sufficient to get you a
reasonably good starting job but it
wasn't necessary
what happened when we expend expanded
higher education was a degree became
necessary but not sufficient
okay
and so you have a bunch of people who
might be better off or happier going
straight into the world of work who are
now required to get a degree
in order to start work at a kind of
level in which they can reach positions
of reasonable reward okay now it wasn't
like that you could you could go into
you know well-paid work without a degree
in 1987. you can't do that now okay very
easily
now
i think if you reserved a whole load of
university places or you discounted
university places for people who'd
worked somewhere first some of these
people may well find out that they loved
the business so much they wouldn't
bother going to university at all but
you'd also create a social norm where
there was nothing weird about not going
to university before you started work
so you'd break that assumption
that
university automatically comes straight
after school but the third requirement
would be if we're going to educate
people it's not a totally crazy
requirement of them to make them prove
that they can actually function in the
real world with other people because i'm
not sure
i was b i'm a bit sad that kenny badnoch
was just knocked out of the conservative
leadership thing because a she didn't
have a degree in ppe from oxford which
is a positive in my book but also she
worked in mcdonald's
now i'm not sure genuinely that in terms
of tacit knowledge understanding of the
world i'm not sure that i wouldn't have
been better off with one year less at
cambridge and one year more working at
mcdonald's
i'm not you know we forget this we have
this extraordinary narrative that
education
adds to people's human capital okay and
that somehow the second you start work
you know you become just
you know you learn nothing
this is completely the opposite of my
experience you know i learned just as
much of my first three years at ogilvy
as i did at three years in university
the idea that working isn't educational
and that there's that the only way you
can add to human capital or value is by
putting people through these incredibly
artificial sort of oblique intelligence
tests which aren't really very good
you're looking at a dropout so
the interesting thing the interesting
thing which must be true statistically
and it must be true simply because
simply because of bill gates and mark
zuckerberg
is that the average harvard dropout is
almost certainly much richer than the
average harvard graduate because even
zuckerberg and gates on their own
would make that a statistical necessity
yeah yeah and i would not be surprised
to hear that because i think it also
points to another characteristic that
those individuals have that is conducive
with success we do have a closing
tradition on this podcast which is the
last guest writes a question for the
next guest yeah
um and this guest has written a question
for you now their handwriting is not
good so this is i've been staring at
this for about 15 minutes trying to
figure out what it says but here we go
um if i asked you at the age of 16 who
in the world you would of liked to be
what would you have said and has your
answer changed
uh
probably not it probably would have been
someone like john cleese um i venerate
comedians the comedian john keys of the
monty python okay
and faulty towers it probably would have
been someone like that i think because i
venerate comedians because they bring
this extraordinary
fresh
i gotta use a fancy epistemology you
know their way of perceiving the world
is in and this is why i'm very much
against politically correct um uh sort
of political activists uh trying to
effectively sense the comedians because
what you're allowing there is for a
group of people who have an incredibly
narrow unsophisticated and moronic
epistemology
to legislate
on people who have a spectacularly
sophisticated and nuanced and um
and complex
sense of perception
it's completely the wrong way around you
know comedians should be able to ban
political activists for being boring in
a healthy world not the other way around
um so yeah i i venerate comedians to a
particular degree i think
um so your answer would have been
um yeah i think i think it would have
been some kind of comedian uh i would
have you know whether later on it might
have been the 9 o'clock news team
i didn't know who he was at the time but
john lloyd who is behind a great deal of
actually very successful advertising uh
but also behind a great deal of very
successful television comedy has to be
considered one of the all-time greats
and has your answer changed no not
really
no i still i still venerate uh those
people you know i'll sit down with
youtube and watch you know three hours
of bill burr and four hours of dave
chappelle dave chappelle by the way you
know as uh in terms of delivery is
we were talking about that whole
business of how you speak
um i mean i i just sit there in awe you
know um and so no those are the people
those are the people that i kind of
can't help but uh venerate
first of all just want to say thank you
it's been a really inspiring
conversation absolutely is really great
it's really challenging in all the right
ways but it's based on so much truth and
experience that i really believe that
it's one of those essential books for
people that are working in this industry
or just in really any industry because
if you're in business the principles
within this book are so applicable to so
many things
um that i feel like it's a really
essential book so thank you for writing
it thank you for being here today it's
been a real honor to speak to you um and
yeah continue being yourself because i
think the world needs a few more people
like you that think in the way you do so
thank you so much keep trying thank you
very much and keep up the good work it's
been fantastic and an inspiration thank
you
quick one as you might know crafted one
of the sponsors of this podcast and
crafted are a jewellery brand and they
make really meaningful pieces of
jewellery the really wonderful thing
about crafted jewelry is it's super
affordable it looks amazing the pieces
hold tremendous meaning and they are
really well made i think i've worn this
piece for almost a year it hasn't broken
hasn't changed color because it's really
really good quality and it costs roughly
50 quid people will be surprised when
they hear that they'll probably assume
that all of my jewelry is like solid
gold and cost thousands and thousands of
pounds but what's the point when you can
achieve the exact same effect from a
piece of jewelry that's high quality and
costs 50 quid that's why i buy crafted
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]